Жодна з гучних корупційних справ в Україні ще не доведена до вироку суду.
Більшість з них або затягуються, або закриваються неочікувано на півшляху.
Ось ці справи.
Це відео, на якому людина, схожа на сина очільника МВС України Олександра Авакова,
домовляється з заступником свого батька Сергієм Чеботарем
про придбання рюкзаків для потреб МВС,
наробило багато галасу кілька років тому.
Ще торік молодшого Авакова навіть затримали.
А тепер неочікувано Спеціалізована антикорупційна прокуратура
закрила кримінальне провадження щодо обох фігурантів справи.
У САПпояснили, що представник фірми-переможця тендера на поставку рюкзаків,
Володимир Литвин, взяв провину на себе.
Саме тому, мовляв, інші два фігуранти справи чисті перед законом,
проти них немає доказів.
У НАБУ назвали це рішення незрозумілим та непослідовним.
Не знайшла САП доказів і проти колишнього міністра екології та природних ресурсів
за часів президента Януковича Миколи Злочевського.
За даними ЗМІ, він навіть повернувся безперешкодно до України.
Кримінальне провадження стосувалось незаконної видачі чиновниками міністерства
дозволів у 2010-2012 роках на користування надрами компаніям,
по'язаним з тодішнім міністром екології Миколою Злочевським.
Ще рік тому виконувач обов'язків міністра охорони здоров'яУляна Супрун звернулася до НАБУ через те,
що їй пропонували хабар у вигляді квартири.
Серед підозрюваних НАБУ виявив помічника депутата Олега Ляшка
та мера Вишневого Іллю Дікова.
Попри відеодоказ надання хабаря, САП не оголосила підозру.
Замість цього голова САП Назар Холодницький повернув справу на доопрацювання
і змінив групу прокурорів, яка над нею працювала.
Голова НАБУ Артем Ситник звинуватив Холодницького
у сприянні меру Вишневого через їхні старі зв'язки.
Про ймовірне втручання Холодницького у справу чути і на плівках запису з його кабінету.
Ще кілька корупційних резонансних справ настільки затягнулись,
що перебувають у зоні ризику їх закриття.
Йдеться, зокрема, про "бурштинову справу" депутата Борислава Розенблата,
справу щодо хабаря голові Центрвиборчкому Михайлу Охендовському
з "чорної каси" Партії регіонів,
розслідування якої САП тимчасово призупинила,
а також справи депутата Миколи Мартиненка та екс-голови ДФС Романа Насірова.
Останній вже звернувся до голови САП з проханням закрити провадження проти нього.